Так виглядає Авдіївка після майже 20-ти днів запеклих боїв.
Тут не залишилося жодного вцілілого будинку.
10 жовтня війська РФ почали активний наступ на місто.
І поступово стирають його з лиця землі.
4-6 авіаударів зберігається щодня,
але це не можна порівняти в ті дні,
коли авіаударів було десятками.
До 50-ти авіаударів за день на таке маленьке місто
- це був певний шок для всіх.
Авдіївка - це райцентр та передмістя окупованого Росією Донецька.
Тут досі залишається понад півтори тисячі місцевих
- під щоденними обстрілами РФ.
- Бомби, бомби, бомби.
Пів сотні бомб на день! Уявляєте, яка ударна хвиля?
- Ховаємося, де можемо. Ракети замордували.
- Обстріли щодня?
- Так, і вночі теж.
Уночі підскакуємо. Тут, напевно, своєю смертю не помреш.
За словами українських військових,
росіяни намагаються витиснути ЗСУ з Авдіївки,
влаштовуючи тут "м'ясні штурми".
Зазвичай вони заходять на українські позиції маленькими групами
по 2-3 людини, інколи йдуть одразу з кількох напрямків.
Якщо перша група гине - за нею слідом іде інша.
Вони 30 метрів підлізають для того,
щоб або кинути гранату, або зробити останній ривок.
Щодня у них якісь втрати є, мінімум щодня якісь втрати.
Тому що їм сказали позицію зайняти.
Їм сказали: все, не відступай.
І все. А в них там втрат видимо-невидимо.
Без бронежилетів, без касок, без нічого. Все.
Один із гранатами, інший із автоматами.
А третій може ще трохи далі прикривати.
Як стверджує Генштаб України, російські штурми Авдіївки -
безрезультатні. А втрати росіян у бронетехніці
та особовому складі - величезні.
За даними речника Сил оборони Таврійського напрямку,
за два тижні атак в районі Авдіївки та Мар‘їнки
війська РФ втратили до 5-ти тисяч вбитими і пораненими та сотні одиниць техніки.
Попри шалені втрати армія РФ продовжує наступ.
По-перше, кидають зараз тих, кого не шкода,
тому що в своїх штурмах російські війська несуть колосальні втрати.
І це помітно, це визнається за статистикою не лише українського Генштабу,
а й незалежних спільнот, оглядачів міжнародних,
які це підтверджують. Тобто втрати, особливо в техніці
і в озброєнні, дуже великі. І так само втрати в живій силі.
Росія намагається певним чином повторити ті способи атак,
які вони проводили в Бахмуті на початку цього року,
залучаючи, тоді це були вагнерівці, зараз це Шторм Z,
Редут та інші. Хоча їхня якість
і якість їхньої підготовки дещо гірша, це очевидно.
Тобто вони не дуже добре навчені,
тим більше відсутня злагодженість між цими підрозділами.
Така тактика - цілком у стилі росіян, вважає німецький військовий експерт Ніко Ланґе.
За його словами, стратегічного значення Авдіївка не має.
Однак росіянам будь-що треба досягнути бодай якогось
військового успіху до президентських виборів.
Це радянський стиль атак.
Російським командирам байдуже, що їхні солдати гинуть.
І тисячі з них гинуть, а машини знищуються.
Але, схоже, є політичне замовлення взяти Авдіївку
будь-якою ціною, не знаю, чи до кінця року, чи, може, навіть до зими.
Але ми знаємо всі ці замовлення,
маю на увазі, що вони ніколи не виконувалися,
тому ми не повинні приділяти занадто багато уваги тому,
що Москва думає, що вони можуть досягти.
Взагалі, як мені здається, стратегічний інтерес Росії
зараз полягає в тому, і Путіна особисто,
щоб просто затягувати війну максимально довго,
очікуючи, що щось може змінитися з виборами в США,
очікуючи, що зміниться підтримка Заходу України,
Україна не буде отримувати таких пакетів допомоги.
І таким чином все-таки вони змусять піти на якісь компроміси,
підписуючи якісь документи про припинення вогню чи перемир'я.
Останніми днями війська РФ активно намагалися
перерізати дорогу до Авдіївки.
Крім того, вони змінили тактику і намагаються оточити місто в "котел",
просуваючись з північного і південного флангів.
На цій карті, складеній з відкритих джерел Інститутом вивчення війни,
жовтим кольором зображені території,
які вважаються завойованими РФ.
За словами аналітиків, російські війська
просунулися приблизно на півтора-два кілометри,
але вони все ще далекі від оточення Авдіївки.
Тим часом Україна встигла підготуватися
та зміцнити свої оборонні позиції тут ще з 2014 року.
Це й не дало росіянам можливості зненацька захопити місто,
влаштувавши бліцкриг, впевнені експерти.
Це оборонні позиції, рубежі, які укріплені,
це укріплені позиції нашої артилерії,
це правильне застосування дронів
різних типів українськими військами,
це артилерія різних типів, яка в нас є,
ствольна, плюс вогнева підтримка танків і бронетехніки,
яка є, підтримка "хаймарсів",
яка забезпечується нашим підрозділам,
і, звичайно, міни.
Тобто мінні поля так само.
Українські сили не сиділи, склавши руки, і розуміли,
що російські підрозділи рано чи пізно будуть наступати,
і потрібно буде захищатися.
Тому ці мінні поля так само тут допомагають у цьому випадку.
Найбільша небезпека, звичайно, якщо порушаться шляхи постачання.
Це на захід від Авдіївки.
Якщо буде така небезпека, це може змусити українські збройні сили залишити це місце.
Але Росія не просунулася дуже далеко,
незважаючи на використання такої кількості солдатів і техніки.
А Авдіївка з 2014 року на передовій.
Тому я не бачу безпосередньої загрози.
Дилема для України, звичайно, полягає в тому,
що Росія зараз просто знищує Авдіївку бомбами.
Але якщо Україна не буде захищати Авдіївку,
Росія перейде до знищення іншого міста.
Ще одна причина масштабної операції росіян із захоплення Авдіївки
- наближення зими.
Адже якщо війська РФ зможуть захопити
більше українських територій,
то взимку почнуть окопуватися і будувати оборонні рубежі
на весну. Також серед причин експерти називають
спробу відволікти ЗСУ від контрнаступу на півдні країни.
З військової точки зору це є відволікання наших підрозділів
і наших дій від півдня з метою остаточно спробувати
зупинити будь-який український контрнаступ.
А ще й на тлі того, що українські посадові особи
- і президент, і командування, і навіть під час конференції Рамштайн в Брюсселі
говорилося про те,  що Україна може продовжити наступальні дії взимку.
Тож, Росії критично важливо змінити фокус уваги
зараз на схід, де, на думку російського командування,
їм набагато легше начебто вести ці наступальні дії.
Якщо взимку будуть сприятливі умови,
то ЗСУ зможуть далі застосовувати в боях важку західну техніку.
А достатня кількість ракет і далекобійної артилерії
дозволить вражати підрозділи російських військ
на глибину їхньої оборони, кажуть експерти.
Я вважаю, що Україна має досвід і готова стримати Росію взимку.
І я очікую, що бої на півдні триватимуть.
Якщо характеризувати зимовий період,
він буде визначатися тим,
що активність основна буде на сході.
Російські війська будуть намагатися вести наступальні дії,
ми оборонятися. У той же час я не виключав
би можливості того, що рейди малими групами
і потужне застосування певних озброєнь буде
і на півдні з українського боку.
Авдіївка знаходиться на вигідній висоті.
Контроль над нею може надати перевагу армії РФ
для просування до кордонів Луганської та Донецької областей.
Якщо росіяни продовжуватимуть перекидати сили на цей напрям
і намагатимуться оточити місто,
ЗСУ будуть змушені вийти з Авдіївки,
аби уникнути значних втрат.
Але наступальна тактика "м'ясних штурмів" росіян
грає на руку Україні, вважають експерти,
оскільки це виснажує війська РФ і затягує час.